I welcome back everyone well many of us
enjoy the benefits of drinking filtered
water but what about cooking cleaning
and bathing in water that's been
purified
jaesi has more well done great jobs of
keeping our hands clean and the surfaces
of our homes clean what about the water
in your home well king water filtration
they've got the solution this is adam
kaplan with king water filtration at if
I do a buddy I'm doing good how about
yourself I can't complain so what makes
your system different than the other
guys well first of all they they don't
require any salt but they're gonna do
everything a water softener is going to
do as far as preventing that damaging
hard water scale and water spotting and
such like that but even more important
than that unlike a water softener
they're gonna be able to remove hundreds
of different contaminants that are
detrimental to your health so you're
telling me I'm gonna get a whole home
water filtration with this system at my
house I got like a brine tank and
there's salt there's all kinds of stuff
this is it right here that's correct
everything is all on that in that one
tank it's gonna be slowly in charge of
salt free conditioning your water and
giving you whole home alkaline drinking
water out of every faucet in your home
so what are some of the impurities that
you guys are taking out of the water
with this system well first and foremost
things like chlorine which they they use
a non municipal water that kill bacteria
and microorganisms we're gonna remove
all of your volatile organic compounds
of which there's literally hundreds of
different ones heavy metals different
pharmaceuticals even certain radioactive
isotopes can be removed from your water
which unfortunately are are common in
our groundwater so let's talk about some
of the other side benefits of getting
your filtration system you're gonna
notice better better lathering so you'll
need to purchase less so you're gonna
notice less lint in your lint screen
because our systems do remove a lot of
the contaminants such as chlorine which
breaks down your clothing fibers making
your clothes last longer and be softer
your hair your skin your nails they're
all gonna be softer when you bathe in it
you're not gonna have that extremely
hard water effect that you do so I'll
stop you right there because I know if
my wife is watching you just said hair
skin and nails that jumped I know that's
coming out to her cuz it's choking out
to me right now because you want that
soft pure water when you're washing your
hair and you're washing your face every
day that's exactly right okay let's talk
about this thing right here
well most most systems like this they're
called reverse osmosis systems and
they're going to do a great job at
removing a lot of the impurities from
your water and such like that however
the problem with it is it almost is too
good of a job in that it's also removing
a lot of those healthy minerals this
system right here is going to remove all
of the impurities but it replenishes the
water with those healthy minerals so
you're going to get highly alkaline
healthy drinking water as well and so
what is that little item there to your
far right this right here is actually
our Terminator filter anybody who
purchased a whole home system will
receive this Terminator filter which
kills all microorganisms bacteria
parasites cysts and even viruses I don't
thank you so much for having this today
what's the website where everybody can
get more information the website is WWE
filtration com for more information call
King water filtration at 7:02 75098 zero
zero or visit their website just like
you said King water filtration com also
they're running a special right now if
you use the promo code skip one you'll
receive a $1000 off any whole house
system plus a free sink filter Las Vegas
now we'll be right back
[Music]